so we begin with a horrific story out of
philadelphia a woman sitting on the
train at 10 pm on wednesday night was
sexually assaulted by a homeless man the
rapist named fistin nagoy sat down
next to the victim tried to touch her
several times she tried to stop him she
pushed back at which point uh he became
more aggressive and started ripping her
clothes off
and this attack went on for eight
minutes
the train was not empty aside from those
two there were other people there there
were other riders in the same car
bystanders bystanders who watched a rape
unfold over the course of nearly 10
minutes and not one of them stepped in
to help the woman
now there are some reports that at least
a few of the onlookers pulled out their
phones and recorded police haven't
confirmed that detail but they have
confirmed that a rape occurred in full
view of a crowd of people and none of
them lifted a finger to help and they
aren't missing words about the
spectators in this case from the new
york times it says quote
i'm appalled by those who did nothing to
help this woman timothy bernhard the
superintendent of the upper darby
township police department said on
sunday
anybody that was on that train has to
look in the mirror and ask why they
didn't intervene or why they didn't do
something mr nagoy 35 was charged with
rape sexual assault and aggravated
indecent assault without consent among
other crimes court records show the
authority said that he was homeless and
was not armed during the attack several
passengers were in the train car but mr
bernhardt declined to say how many
investigators were still working on to
determine the exact number he said uh he
said while there while there were not
dozens of people in the car at the time
there were enough that quote
collectively they could have gotten
together and done something bystanders
on the train who failed intervene could
be criminally charged if they recorded
the attack
mr bernhard said
now a few things should be said at the
outset first the primary villain in this
case is not the group of useless
bystanders but the perpetrator
that shouldn't need to be said but i say
it anyway because these days the people
who commit these evil acts tend to be
tacitly led off the hook lost in the
shuffle as we debate the circumstances
around the act and what sorts of things
could have been done to stop it and who
should have done whatever those things
are
the rapist is the one responsible in a
serious country would ensure that he
never sees the outside of a prison cell
ever again in his life but we don't live
in that kind of country and philadelphia
is not that kind of city
violent crimes are at record levels in
philly right now as the da's in
philadelphia and in the surrounding
districts this crime will be prosecuted
by jack steimer in
delaware county right outside the city
they're all progressive ideologues who
were elected to their positions with the
help of george soros
now this is not a conspiracy theory as
the media likes to portray any mention
of sorrows
the minute you mention it is a
conspiracy theory as if he's a fictional
character um he's not it is a confirmed
fact that the billionaire the left-wing
billionaire took an interest in
philadelphia district attorney races a
few years ago and he poured millions of
dollars into electing his preferred
candidates
the city is a brutal violent hellscape
even more than it was before
all this to say that the rapist
homeless and a black man checking
several of the victim boxes will likely
be out on the street again in no time
and we'll return to that point in just a
moment
with all that said of course the
bystanders are still a bunch of weak
gutless cowards cowards again if we
lived in a serious country the rapists
would not have walked out of there
instead of this infuriating and
sickening story we should be reading
about
the inspiring tale of a scumbag who
attempted to lay one hand on a woman and
was summarily beaten unconscious by an
enraged mob of men that's the way it
should have ended
but again that's not the kind of country
we live in and so these kinds of stories
very rarely end that way
we know that violent crimes are often
committed in view of onlookers who could
step in and help but choose not to and
we know that because so often as they
allegedly did in this case the onlookers
elect instead to record the crime on
their phones and that's how we know
about it
yet this problem predates smartphones
we've known about the so-called
bystander effect for a long time and
many famous cases have been documented
through the years
there's always the potential in these
kinds of situations for bystanders to
freeze up fail to act hoping that
somebody else will take care of the
problem
the tendency is so much a part of the
human condition that it made it into the
gospels two thousand years ago with the
parable of the good samaritan
you know the sole person who stops to
help a man who was beaten by bandits and
left for dead on the side of the road
it is unfortunately a tale as old as
time or at least as old as the human
race
this is no excuse for the people in the
crowd who fail to do the right thing
it's just a matter of understanding how
deeply embedded this problem is
though even so
anecdotal evidence like all these videos
that we see all the time would seem to
suggest that the bystander effect is
worse now more prevalent than ever
before people are less willing to put
their necks out less eager to do the
right thing
when doing the right thing may put them
in jeopardy
and they have it would seem far less
shame about their own cowardice
why is that i think that's the important
question
well there are many things many many
contributing factors but let's start
with the fact that unlike years past
the system now actively discourages
people from intervening
i was somewhat annoyed to read those
comments from the local authorities
condemning the onlookers
even though i agree with the
condemnation i agree with
what they said
but
this is partially the fault of those
local authorities
this is partially their fault
with far left da's in office all across
the country and especially especially
all over the philadelphia area
there's no telling what would happen to
somebody if they used physical force to
neutralize an attacker
and that's the case even if you're
defending just yourself
you're defending someone else getting
involved in a situation that didn't that
you were not immediately involved in
who knows i mean if a good samaritan had
stepped up and given the perpetrator the
beat down that he so desperately
deserved
it's not hard to imagine that that same
good samaritan might face assault
charges the next day
might end up being smeared by the media
as a racist vigilante
this is the exact dilemma that police
officers all over the nation face every
single day and it's their job and their
express legal obligation and authority
to intervene
how much worse could the blowback be for
somebody who doesn't have that express
obligation or authority whereas in years
past a good samaritan had to only weigh
the risk to his own physical safety
before getting involved now he knows
that even if he survives the encounter
his life may still be over after the
fact depending on how it all plays out
and also depending quite significantly
on the racial demographics involved
now this again is not to provide any
excuses for anybody
we're called to take risks sometimes
very significant risks if we wish to be
decent men
i'm only pointing out that the systems
running this country actively discourage
and punish decency
and besides
many people don't wish to be decent men
in the first place you know as children
were conditioned from a young age to
regard questions of moral decency as
superfluous or even oppressive
the message we absorbed from our culture
is that our own physical and
psychological well-being should come
before everything and everybody else
so we we sneer
at moral decency
and we actively punish it
and then we stand back in shock and
horror to find that people are not
decent
we look at the police officer in the
micaiah bryant shooting
he stepped in to stop
a a girl from getting stabbed to death
and next thing you know people are
calling for his head
lebron james is tweeting out a picture
of him
trying to rile up a mob to go in
and
do who knows what to him
that's the way it goes now
and it reminds me of one of the greatest
lines from one of c.s lewis's greatest
books the abolition of man which if
you've never read you should
writing 80 years ago though it might as
well have been yesterday lewis says
quote
in a sort of ghastly simplicity we
remove the organ and demand the function
we make men without chess and expect of
them virtue and enterprise
we laugh at honor and are shocked to
find traitors in our midst
we castrate and bid the geldings be
fruitful
that's us
our culture campaigns against virtue and
punishes the virtuous you can't even go
to church anymore to hear a defense of
virtue
we have purposefully created a society
of hollow people
men without chests
we're surprised by the results
we shouldn't be well i hope you enjoyed
that clip from the matt wall show if you
did go ahead and hit that subscribe
button right down there so you can stay
up to date on all of our future content